jumping into halloween i am curious um
when the movie came out the first one
you guys made it on a budget what was
your like optimistic goal of what this
might make at the worldwide box office
were you like maybe if we get to 50
million this is going to be great
i was a real pessimist and i think a lot
of my career has kind of beaten me down
with with uh like beating the optimism
out of the box office for my own
um
ideas so i remember there was a moment
on set
where i was really down there was a
there was a tattoo on a dummy of miles
robbins that was looking kind of
questionable and we were struggling with
lighting and trying to make this effect
look real and the camera i was like
nobody's going to see this movie i'm
just i'm just another one i'm just
halloween 11. that's all i am i'm
howling in 11 and nobody's gonna give a
[ __ ] except you know eight people and
the camera department says no this
movie's gonna make a hundred million
dollars we we're sure of it and i'm like
you know what if
if it's if it um if it makes 100 million
dollars i'm gonna get that tattoo on
bitchnet that miles robins has on his
arm and so so the opening day of the
movie
or not opening day the movie actually
opened in a movie they reminded me of
the bet and so then on the date on uh on
10 31 18 i had to get my first tattoo
which i'd always said i would never get
one but in those circumstances with that
type of uh of a success it was it was no
question just to to have a group of
collaborators that's that confident and
something in my moments of doubt and
security
um because inevitably everybody
everybody with any artistic sensibility
has a little bit of that neuroses and
that
that sense of being underappreciated um
and uh and i have that all the time
sure i'm assuming you didn't make a bet
on the second movie for box office
did not did not well that's what's so
crazy too as we made the movie two years
ago and it's been sitting on a shelf for
a year
and so
who who knows and then we've got a
peacock streaming component of this
movie that adds to the uncertainty of it
of not only are we in a competitive
landscape of these big blockbuster
movies
um
you know we're a seasonal movie and we
are a franchise movie and i think we're
gonna um i think we're gonna do pretty
good but it's it's it's always
you never know on on
weeks like this where you're leading up
to the the anticipation of a release
it's just to me that's just exciting i
like i like the butterflies i've gotten
my stomach this morning
do you think that do you think kenny
powers could take down michael myers
no he would be destroyed yeah
not even close
although danny did this morning he just
read the draft for um
uh halloween ends he was working on some
stuff and he's like he's like i think i
think i might need a cameo i need to
fight that [ __ ]
well i actually wondered and there's
something some uh someone on the
collider staff asked us um did you ever
consider having danny mcbride play uh
michael
not no not not michael but you know it
we always entertain it's fun when he
comes to set because everybody's like
when's he jumping in
um this is another question someone on
the staff asked did you use the same
property for laurie stroll strode's
murder house trap as you did on for neil
gamby's house in season 2 of vice
principals it's not it's it's funny we
scouted that house for for gambie's
house and then did not end up using it
but when i was riding laurie's house i
was riding with that in mind because
we'd scouted it
make sense
100 um when you were making the first
one how much had you guys actually
figured out about the trilogy or at the
time were you sort of like you know
let's just make one movie we'll figure
out if we're gonna do more later in
terms of the story we had a lot of ideas
and then a very first fat draft of the
first one we had a big haddenfield
community component
um with some remo
returning characters but we ended up
being afraid of the ambition and scope
of that so we kept it a little bit more
contained praying for success so that we
could then expand it and then
then we we had a lot of
ideas at the buffet table of what we
would do
and then it was coming up with that
ending and and how we concluded in
halloween ends did you end up getting
into any battles with the mpaa or are
they pretty much like they know this is
going to be very violent and you don't
have to shave any frames
there were no
you know i always have conversations
with them about things like when i'm
making mangle horn you know like why is
this rated r there's no profanity drug
use sex or anything why why are you
trying to rate it and then i have to go
appeal to have a pg-13 movie
um but with this movie which is
disgusting and and gratuitous
and grotesque it's like
yeah you would think that you would have
conversations but it seems to
seems to be swallowed pretty easily i
guess
it's so funny to me man i mean i have
such strong feelings i'm not going to
make you say anything about the mpaa but
i have such strong feelings about how
full of [ __ ] they are because that you
could literally if you in halloween
kills you can do the most crazy stuff to
people no problem but if you show part
of a boob oh that's r rated oh in prince
avalanche
that paul rudd emil hirsch maybe i made
a few years ago there's no profanity no
violence but one time
emile talks about fingering
and it's a rated r movie
that's the only that's the only
off color note in the entire film and
it's rated r i mean for that movie
you're like it's not worth a fight but
you're like really
dude i i have such strong feelings um so
i'm curious about with the with this
film uh the new the new halloween did
you have a much longer first cut or how
efficient are you filming
on you know what i mean with the budget
you have and the time
um
this was a
85-page script
um i like short scripts i never i never
go into production with anything over a
93 page script because i know i play and
then every 93 page script is gonna be a
two hour first cut and this was probably
an hour and 50 minute first cut we
i'm not i don't know that there's any
deleted scenes but we tightened some
stuff up and and went for the momentum
rather than
um
you know it's not a very patient and
profound
pace to the movie so we yeah we just
kind of tightened it up and but it was
it was wild every single day was
difficult it was seven weeks of nights
and
and we're all in like this crazy dream
like surreal state of mind making it and
then i think it's and i think it's
reflected in the movie i think there is
a little bit of a
dreamy abstract surreal quality to it
i just interviewed keanu for his comic
book and he was telling me that he's
been filming for like three and a half
months on wick
um you know shooting nights and you can
like see in his eyes when he talks about
it like he's lu you know what i mean
like it's you become just a different
person i guess i've never done that
before
yeah it's really i mean you go to bed
when the sun comes up and and sometimes
there's an opportunity there's a big
fight sequence with the community versus
michael in this movie and and we lost
the the night and so i'm like well we
still got like 11 kills to go and we
have it's daylight and so we just ended
up re-staging it on a stage
put michael on a turntable and basically
had an assembly line of victims enter
the turntable as he's spinning and and
we're like this is never going to work
this is this is absurd
but it became one of my
favorite sequences in the movie because
you've just never seen a slaughter like
this before that is like a strange
ballet of violence
um uh i'm curious with the ending of
this film um how did you guys decide
where you wanted to end this one and was
it oh was it always this or did you have
another option
there's actually you'll we're going to
do a this is the director's cut
through and through but there's an
additional scene that we filmed that was
scripted and actually i think is a
pretty brilliant scene so we're going to
do an extended version on the dvd just
so people can see
a an extended ending
um that's that's different and cool and
we ended up lifting it when i became
more confident of where we're going to
pick up in the next movie it felt like
it was the it was didn't feel authentic
to where we're going to go
so we lifted it so we just said you know
we're kind of coming up with okay then
if we lift that
where do we end and it was actually um
cooper cooper samuelson at blumhouse it
was just like let's just end when it's
over
lights out
so you know he he mentioned it like he
was like remember in rogue one when you
wanted the movie to end when it was just
darth vader going ballistic at the door
and like i was like yes
well mike my question is is the scene
that you cut that will be in the
extended version is that a scene that
like is a canon is it like is it part of
the movie or is this just like a fun
other scene
it's it's part of the movie it's just
not part of the appropriate momentum of
of
yeah i think
it was cool in its own right as watching
a one-off movie but knowing where we're
gonna exactly we're gonna pick up which
you'll know in a year
um it wasn't the right
look in the eye that we needed to to
give the audience
and i don't know if you want to talk
about this and if you don't then we'll
i'll just not bring it you know to say
you don't want to but with the ending of
the film you have you can interpret the
ending with what's going on with michael
in like i think two different ways and
i'm just curious if you want to talk
about what you wanted to have happen
with him uh or what you were looking for
the audience to get out of that ending
or you know with him i don't i don't
know how much you want to say
i don't yeah i think a lot of it you
know like any ending that has any degree
of ambiguity for the filmmaker's
perspective you're just like let's get
people talking less people go go see the
movie and let's talk about it later and
see
what what we think um
but it's it's it's hard he's a hard
character to write for because you got
to create some sort of magnetism
and motivation for someone that has no
magnetism or motivation
he doesn't talk he doesn't give you
anything he's expressionless and
emotionless and he is just going
somewhere or he's wandering somewhere so
it we we tried to send some sort of
beacon
and in this movie it's it's his
childhood home
um and what that means to him and what
that does to him when he arrives
who gets to keep the mask at the end of
the shoot or is it the same mask on
every like did you use the same mask on
halloween and this one and the next one
or do you sort of say uh we should make
a few extra masks because i want to keep
one from each movie we make two masks
for each movie and this was different
because it evolved because he was um
cooking in the basement for a little
while so we wanted to have some
uh new texture on it
and there's two masks that you make and
i get one and christopher nelson gets
one at the end of the day that's the
deal and and uh so yeah my office is
starting to get a little creepy
that do you have them like did you have
you framed them or they just how do you
display them i got them in those those
little bell jar what do you call those
things those little glass yeah cases
that they're mounted and looking
looking sinister
got it you should if you don't mind you
should take a photo and release a photo
because i think fans a i want to see
them and b i know fans would love to see
them yeah well it's fun whenever i zoom
from back in charleston where i live
they're always in the background looking
over me uh making keeping an eye on me
making sure i don't talk [ __ ]
i am riddled with jealousy just riddled
um how
one of the things that's interesting
about this film i guess my and i don't
know how much you can say about the the
last installment of halloween but um
where are you guys in the writing
process have you do you guys can you
talk about where you are in the
scripting process yeah well i mean a
week ago i said we're done and then a
few bright ideas and conversations like
this that inspire me and and then i i
and i'm reunited with a lot of the cast
members and doing the the press junket
and so i think
so i'm just been watching the movie with
a new
new eye
so i did get to work this weekend and
made some revisions and i'll be doing
that until we're done editing you know
we we really do
keep ourselves as writers um i've got
two new
writing collaborators on this with with
me and danny uh paul logan and chris
bernier are just huge halloween fans and
so we always try to bring new voices
into the mix and so they they poke holes
in our story and they play devil's
advocate and they bring new ideas and
new reference points and
so yeah this weekend all weekend i was
rampaging on a new new pass of it but we
start prep
uh in two weeks and and so they're
wanting me to lock in something more
definitive which i think will be in good
shape for that to shoot in january
do you mind can i ask if you're going to
does the next film the third film uh
does it start right after the second
film ends the way you did it with the
second film or is there a time jump it's
a time jump it gets back back on to a um
contemporary timeline so it'll jump four
years uh it's interesting because i was
i was thinking you had to do something
like that because you want to have you
know jamie more in the action not
suffering from like a stomach
kind of you know what i mean yeah that's
a big thing and you know a lot of this
movie was tricky not only in writing the
shape and his lack of character but but
keeping her
um in a realistic scenario you know
there's a very there's a graphic surgery
that we film of her and and then once
you've done that it's not she's not
going to be doing a lot of kung fu so
100 um do you envision the the your
third film as like the ending of the
halloween saga do you want it to
continue after you're
done
i mean my ego says create something that
is a four-part
series
beginning with carpenter's 1978 film and
then our our follow-up trilogy and i'm
sure the mythology takes over and
michael and laurie will emerge in some
new capacity with some new filmmaker
storyteller
behind them but for me
uh i'll i'll be done and and i hope
they'll take a little time off before
they resuscitate it but that's just my
ego yeah
um when do you actually film the
movie in january
uh okay so you're a few months you say
oh i got it so is that a no that's cool
so you have a few months to really get
it together
uh
yeah i guess you could call it that
let me say a few months to get the
script you know what i'm saying yeah the
script's in great shape it's just a
matter of like you know committing to
certain paths and and uh and characters
and
and constructing new set pieces and then
you get into the realities of schedule
and budget and people say you know what
happens if you lose that scene you save
some time and money and can use that
somewhere else i don't know you know you
get into that type of massage
so i never look at anything it's done
until we're sound mixing
i won't press you any further on that um
listen man i really do think you did a
great job with uh the second halloween
film also as you know making the second
chapter is really [ __ ] hard
like it absolutely is so see it in the
theater see it big see it pretty see it
loud and uh and i hope people enjoy it